[Applause]
philly it's
crazy out there yeah north philly oh
[ __ ] you're from south philly
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true dude so
the suburbs is where the
rich folks live yeah it's a lot of white
flight everybody got money got out when
you're there like whenever i did shows
in philly and i was around that kind of
what's that center city
yes it's center city that's all right
yeah there's like a 15
yeah there's like 15 there's written
house squares there a lot of old money
there
yeah yeah yeah but dude you go like
outside of that very
center city pocket even at night the
center city gets [ __ ] dicey
yeah yeah yeah yeah my but why is it so
bad is it mafia [ __ ] gang [ __ ] like what
is it it's not
gangs it's not really it's just like
it's like block to block it's just
[ __ ] a lot of poverty a lot of guns
you can get guns like in pennsylvania
you can
there's like no like new york doesn't
have that many guns ah so there's
violence
a lot of violence got you and the gun
laws are really
lenient yeah okay interesting like you
can go buy 15 handguns at a time
even in the city yeah yeah yeah
cvs or anything yeah but you know what
i'm saying like in new york for example
like if you live upstate you could
probably get a rifle super easy but in
new york city
you can't you can't you can't have a gun
yeah i think you're shooting himself
right really yeah yeah you can literally
what they do is they send one guy in
with a clean record
to go in and buy like 15 handguns and
then he goes and just
gives them out he gets straw purchases
yeah real real
real quick when you get outside that's a
bad combination yeah i never
understood why philly is so is so rough
but maybe it's because like
sometimes what happens when there's like
a decently sized city that's close to
a major city you kind of drain sure all
the folks oh yeah that's sure
even you guys come in here like you
could stay in philly and do stand up
there but obviously new york there's
gonna be more opportunities you go and
i'm sure the same [ __ ] happens with
business or whatever
yeah but it just doesn't make sense
because i think someone's telling
philly's like the seventh biggest city
in the country
or something like that yeah yeah
i think you're right it's a brain drain
it's like why would i stay here if
you're here
you can go to new york and make two
hours to the city baby
kidding me yeah [ __ ] hit the lincoln
tunnel the city in america is new york
yeah this is the city and imagine you're
two hours away from
yeah and like everything is there
commerce is all there and
there's entertainment there whatever you
are for the best restaurants go to new
york
you want fame that's the spot did you
guys start stand up in philly
yeah yeah yeah okay it was
it was good it was it's like it's like
one of the it's a northeast so it's like
philly boston new york right it's the
same mentality
a lot of ball busting a lot of blue
collar [ __ ] families it's like
my family's huge my mom's 1-9 they're
huge it's all like irish catholic
[ __ ]
construction workers and like i'm like
the 15th funniest dude in my family like
wait
your family's all construction workers
yeah yeah and you couldn't finish a shed
yeah my stepdad owns a huge construction
company
[Applause]
i have an unfinished head for 10 years
finally like they my mom was like
thanksgiving with the whole family yeah
everybody bring your hammers dog
to put on yeah it's super yeah we're
super garbage
we got a huge hole in our basement
waiting on an insurance check to come
through let's go
okay yeah but it's interesting because
like there's so many comics that come
from philly
that have had a lot of success in new
york but
i feel like it philly's not spoken about
as a comedy city in the way that boston
is
yeah well i think it's distance it's
like when you start getting good
in philly you it's so you can still live
in philly and come up to new york a
couple times a week to start getting
your name and start getting some reps
meeting people whereas boston dudes
stayed in boston they stayed in boston
the whole philly is slept on as a talent
city like will smith
[ __ ] boys to men kevin hart there's
massive people from philly and you don't
think about it
but i think comedy needs a couple of
more big people from philly because
boston had
everybody you loved 10 years ago whether
it was dane cook or louis ck
patrice o'neill or bill burke they're
all from boston so you couldn't
look away from it you're like oh we slip
in too we slip in
yeah we slip in and then [ __ ] you
know get mixed up down the village for a
few years
on this scene or over here level that's
it i mean yeah that's good we don't roll
in big dick and we come in on the mega
bus
yeah it's true there's like uh
um how do i say it's like uh they
haven't had superstars yet they've had
like new york stars
yeah outside of kevin hart like like we
if you came up in the new york comedy
scene like you saw these guys that came
up from philly
yeah yeah kurt metzger
like so many guys come up from philly so
like in your head you're like man these
philly dudes are hilarious
but the only mega star so far is kev
so if you're somebody outside of new
york you might not be the four boston
guys i named they were everybody your
favorite comic is one of those forces
yeah they're
all from boston at some points like yeah
dudes yeah
dude back to the 80s like they were
dicks from boston
no hicks was texas that's right leno i
think was from
leno was up there i think he went to
school i don't know if he was from up
there but he went to school up there and
started
marin's up there as well that's right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they had a little move also they
have the tv show too
you know and then that movie when stand
up stood out propaganda piece they put
out but then
yeah them four is undeniable like
[ __ ] that's one city you put that
together and you're like god damn you
don't new york
is you know new york is not to be slept
on either though
like people coming from new york yeah
like comedians
yeah that's the thing i'm thinking like
how many of us are actually from new
york rock
rock seinfeld murphy that's the emerald
generation i'm trying to wonder like the
new generation oh no you guys stink now
isn't that crazy
i'm trying to think who else besides me
is chrissy
that's a good point i was just trying to
think it's so rare like i even have
these conversations with like ricky when
we're coming up we're like
yo who else is actually from the city
and why aren't people doing it and maybe
sometimes when like
it's so accessible to you you don't lean
into it
you know like when you're when you're
from outside of the place to be
you want it so much more because it's
like right out here
yeah you're like when did we move into
new york that was the conversation
you're like how do i get up there i got
to get a job i can find some way to get
up there and i think
maybe sometimes people take it for
granted when it's right in front of them
it's like when these people that live on
the
live on the beach don't surf okay yeah
yeah yeah and it's just like
i don't know that happened to me even
like in college i was like i'm just
gonna go to college in california surf
all the time like surf like twice it was
like right there
you know you gotta really [ __ ] want
if it's right in front of you man